[Music]
so
your hair was in the toilet water
disgusting
oh this whole thing
so we did talk about brandon sharp and
boy has it gotten
super weird yeah so
wait are you saying it's coming out that
he's probably probably just
an [ __ ] not really a cool guy
apparently he's a real dick so this is
um
bobby lee
and his
girlfriend yeah fiance girlfriend i
don't she's awful i was i was shocked to
find out bobby lee is 50. you asians
really don't eat no it's frightening
well they either don't age or they age
really badly he looks like still looks
like mad tv bobby lee you know
uh so anyway this is um
we're gonna skip around look i'm gonna
apologize up front i have to apologize
up front
this is from an h3 podcast it is
objectively [ __ ] terrible
unfortunately is where we're getting our
information but we could also make fun
of ethan at the same time so look win
win so we are we do want to warn
everybody that we're uh we're moving our
um our blink warning up to a jim norton
level all right so there's going to be a
jim norton amount of blinking and
twitching in this video let's see i'm
going to do that hey there eliana oh
that's not it
right imagine that's how brandon chops
hitting on her brandon shaw's going to
come out with a video and be like yo b
like look my former friend
like you know what i mean she's lying
because she was my friend and i did care
about her b
i hate him
your
[Music]
a wreck of a human yeah
i'd love to talk about what why don't
you want to talk about brendan schwab
but you're down
so
brendan schaab
well here's what i'll say about brendan
schwab schwab schwab
schwab
yeah yeah
i'm gonna skip around a little bit 100
okay yeah shred tread lightly i will
tread lightly so you guys were doing a
show
and you said that someone you guys knew
was trying to pick up you don't want to
even say
well just correct me where i'm wrong we
don't need to stress you guys
i hate her
oh that's a chick yeah that's a woman oh
wow yeah that's not dating hypernova
it's gonna distress him because
okay go ahead ethan
you okay bobby
so you guys said yeah this guy brendan
schwab you alluded to it you said his
initials was bs everybody now knows it's
him right um well the first time that we
had talked you know it was
um it was a story about someone who had
hit on me seven years ago
brandon
it was a story about someone we never
said his name during the first show
brendan
but lately
with no intention other than to just
tell a story about the funny story
interesting just to get a good laugh
something that i thought might be really
good when i look at you i think i can't
wait i'm ready to laugh yeah i can't
wait for the [ __ ] the fun and games
to begin
ago he tried to pick you up this
comedian um yeah i told him on trash
tuesday he looks so uncomfortable which
is like yeah he tried it and the story
was interesting he brought you to the
car and tried to get a blowy or
something that's not me oh that was one
of the other girls annie yeah and um
because it's
such an interesting way to pick up a
girl i think to be like yo you want to
come to my car and suck my [ __ ] hey
ethan can i can i se for a career stream
hey then can i say something this
[ __ ] modern art picture can i
say something even
i'm not defending brennan here but do
you know for some guys that works right
yeah
like i'm not i'm not trying to like
i'm not of course jobs of [ __ ] [ __ ]
but
some dudes can't do that you don't think
if rogan woke up to chick even if he
never talked your after show and be like
hey want to go to my car and suck my
dick
you're going to say yes
anyway i should preface this by saying i
had a phone call with him all is squared
away and fine but he did promise we
promised that this would never be
brought up again but then he went on
flagrant too and talked about it so i
was like all right deal's off i'm going
to talk about it on http
yeah so um
but i'll be delicate about it because i
do think um spoiler alert
it's not like is it sure
you know um
yeah i don't want to be an [ __ ] to
anybody yeah oh god right it's it's
really rough to look at right it's
really rough to look at yeah
um but are you friends with him is that
the problem are you friends with with
brendan
you're a queen census yeah yeah
do you think he's a funny comedian
because there's a lot of people i think
he's great okay
i think it's wonderful
i really do dynamic you know can i say
something about him all right i want to
say this all right um i want to say that
you try to get you try to [ __ ] your girl
all right so short is she short yeah um
i like to say this about the man all
right you know how difficult it is to go
from one like god what
you don't have to like
do
she is right she's not respectful i know
she doesn't but i'm just i'm pointing
him out as
he's well he's a weak [ __ ] she's only
with him for the money yeah but yeah she
has no respect for him no what right
you're you know what you're being a
power bottomer okay so um you know it's
very difficult to go from one profession
to another right
yeah but that doesn't mean that you
should like i get it bobby and this is
my problem and no bobby it's not hard to
be bad at two things yeah you could play
i tried something and was bad at it so
i'm now i'm doing a new thing and i'm
bad at it that's not admirable
right
really successful fighter very
successful um what was his professional
record
it's not the record that counts it's
that's
the only thing that counts it's the main
thing that's the only thing that counts
in fighting is true i think do you think
that uh like the top fighters in ufc
right now are like that's just a loss
just my win loss record who cares it's
what you do in the ring you know i mean
it's commitment mm-hmm what does he do
in the ring yeah it does take can you
guys call his profession his
professional record
what does that matter i'm
curious you know they say that like our
show we never get to the point and
and that we like
interrupt things all the is it me or
like can we get to this story or are we
going we're gonna we have to compliment
brendan schaub first oh okay
and i don't wanna so um
anyway so he you know and he goes into a
very difficult medium which is stand-up
comedy it's yeah it's clicky it's very
difficult it's very difficult yeah and
he's part of the main clique immediately
what do you mean that's hard yeah i know
it's exciting it's like it's like
literally having the cool jock from an
80s movie
be the first bird like to be his cousin
and be going to the new school it's like
you'll be flying dude yeah you gotta
draft it to the super bowl winning team
he's gonna be fine exactly yeah he
carves his way out and he does a couple
of specials he's a successful podcaster
and my hat's off to him what do you
consider
successful what do you consider a
podcaster what do you consider a
comedian yeah okay
yeah very okay good i mean nice things
awesome
all good vibes um we've we've talked and
um everything's under the rug and
everything's fine
and um
yeah
although
he broke in he's a broken man and look i
kind of get i do understand his side of
it which is like okay you do have to go
hang out with these people later at the
[ __ ] comedy clubs and stuff like that
but who cares like this is the one thing
that i've always said about a lot of
comedians that kind of bugs me right
like
they have this honor code with each
other which i think is kind of silly you
know
which is like football players talk [ __ ]
about each other all the [ __ ] time
you know
it's it's just like even if objectively
you know somebody is bad right like
brandon chob is bad like this this isn't
one of those like well everyone has
different tastes brendan chop's just bad
all around and it's like no i want to
talk should have another comic but i
mean they all talk [ __ ] about brendan
when no one's recording them like
everybody's honest about it but it's
this whole like no actually br the
reason we're going gonna have more
brendan chops because not enough people
in that little click are going like bro
you suck yeah all these edgy comedians
that speak truth to power but then they
won't pick on each other at all yeah
exactly sensitive exactly so i would
like to clarify
nice things to say so i mean you're in
the middle of your story well my problem
with the whole thing was
um when he had a problem with me he went
through bobby bobby was a filter and i
thought that was really um
not appropriate no
cake can i uh i gotta take a side here
with redness
absolutely that's the way you do it to
be like hey man your girl said this
about me like what's that about you know
because you don't want you that's
actually more respectful
you know
he wouldn't talk to you
no i i i want to protect bobby in all of
this yeah it's what it seems like huh
oh he was ten and five that's not bad
we're [ __ ] we're not [ __ ] we're [ __ ]
why
little things like that what does that
mean it means is there a hierarchy yes
no i mean we all know there is but it's
they never they never really mention it
but but this proves to you oh so there's
like a hierarchy like there's a you know
that you would argue that the king is
rogan right he's he's the head honcho if
you will
of this whole group and it's like oh
we're [ __ ] because everybody's friends
and you have to be nice to brendan even
though brendan sucks you have to be nice
to him yeah wait why are you though what
did i say about him wait is this hold on
really is that ten losses or five
you're so afraid of being bullied
while she
while she bullies him
hey stand up for you get confident
stupid stand up for yourself [ __ ]
what is that i could never live like
this i could never yeah between all of
these people would just be an erotic
mess yeah why are you so afraid because
this is the problem it all and it to his
defense
when
when shaab had a problem with me never
even saying his name and by the way i
neither confirm or deny that that's to
this day that that story was about him
like but it is i mean you've just you've
just been using it to cite a thing yes
yeah you guys said his initials was bs
and then annie said it was bob saget
but that's the joke and it wasn't bob
saget yeah because we know both know you
[ __ ] would have blown bob saget yes
that man was a legend of course on the
live show well and then no one wants to
get bs
no one of the things i think bob saget
record when he was alive recorded
himself having sex and did the funny
voice over for america's finding his own
videos just to amuse himself
things that really gave it away yeah is
that you guys said that he's not very
funny as a comedian and then you guys
all started laughing objective
no but i know i disagree why do you
disagree what do you find funny about
brennan's shot bobby i need to
understand what is it that he does is it
when he goes
yes when he talks about spanish words
or is that when he rips off dave
chappelle by hitting his leg with a
microphone is that it or when he walks
around the stage like brian callan he's
literally a and i've mentioned this
before but brendan schaub is a [ __ ]
voltron put together from everything
he's but put together shitty like the
arms to the head [ __ ] voltron he'd
be like pieces of go different gobots
yeah exactly together [ __ ] just
terrible you're you're a [ __ ] great
value power ranger set
you're [ __ ] terrible right now
yeah exactly and it'd be like ninja
warriors but they would all have this
thing i'll be the same that's like a
meme about him i know you think he's
funny yeah but there's like a meme that
everyone's like he's the george carl
over he's not funny that doesn't mean
that they necessarily said right it's
him okay shut up
it's like how you say
a cucumber
a cucumber
[ __ ] hate this [ __ ]
so i actually to this day
i you never said his name i never said
it was assumed i didn't think that it
would escalate in the way that it did i
also didn't realize that bobby would
take the brunt of the punishment
um because nothing you know he didn't do
anything i didn't do anything right
i didn't do [ __ ] i [ __ ] rigged [ __ ]
here's my problem with just even this in
general okay
and is that i'm going to be iced out
from the laugh factory i mean i feel
like this store yeah oh comedy
i apologize comedy store
since it's already talking about it [ __ ]
it right good luck good luck playing in
austin bobby
that's rogan's town
what i'm saying to you is is that i have
nothing to do with any of it i don't
even know what oh frozen is that you
that's not me that's bobby lee okay okay
so maybe you're bobby lee are you bobby
lee i've never seen you two together
yeah you're both asian you're both
easily bullied yeah you know
yeah
frozen that might be true or not but god
damn it
the [ __ ] thing is about really you
don't like being put in the middle of it
not was i not put in the middle of it i
was being um
screamed at
and bullied it was like
get your [ __ ] in line phone yeah
it was worse than that it was way worse
than that and my point is is that sorry
that's this now my fear is
the results of whatever this is now
going to be there's no results because
there is there is a result
i can call shaub right now and we could
be like all is squared away and
everything is fine because we've already
talked about it the promise was that he
would never talk about it again and the
next day he went on flagrant too and
then talked about it even though it was
in a complimentary way yeah in a
complementary way i i don't feel like
we've said anything bad about him either
the point is did was there um
was there a text
alluding to possibly
suing people yes there was did it did it
freak me out and did it make me think oh
[ __ ] so
so shabba is just on like a suing frenzy
is that what's happening
a a text threatening to sue people
shop man you know what george you know
what george carlton never did all right
have to sue other comics to prove he was
funny or to not tell stories about him
that's crazy
like such a small thing to sue over but
was there a lot of misunderstanding from
his team no there's misunderstanding
because of the traumatic brain injury
that he got from being punched in the
head so many times he doesn't know words
yeah he's not good at them us yeah and
but we talked it through but the truth
is the truth
and you know it's all squared away
so yeah it seems like it
you guys are just going to get this
clear so you guys were talking about
there was this comedian that people
assumed was him yeah that was trying to
pick up all you girls kind of a sleaze
whatever right
so he calls you
and says bobby
get your get your woman in line i mean
what kind of get your [ __ ] in line it
would be with the line you're looking
for sir get that hoe in line [ __ ]
animal does that that's [ __ ] up why
didn't they call you what kind of animal
does that guy's for
kim sorry but everyone's of years
everybody in this in this video and
everything they're all terrible right
they're all terrible this [ __ ] loser
over here thinks that
that's how men don't handle things that
is exactly how men handle things not
defending shop he's none funny [ __ ] and
i get it but we're also pretending like
what kind of person does that normal men
yeah people who have testosterone sick
dude why is she doing like yeah is she
pissed what's going on you know she got
a period
[ __ ] animal does that that's [ __ ]
up why didn't they call you [ __ ]
animal blundetto
what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] it was not
just him
there was a whole barrage it was it was
don't say the name i'm not gonna but it
was a phone call with other podcasters
and it was that's some [ __ ] they
flogged you bro enough logged me they
threatened my career
yeah
okay i haven't got to this part sorry
because i'm we've been we've been busy
but
can we try to guess who these other
podcasters were
sure okay i'm gonna guess rogan
you you think it got to the dawn because
he's the dawn right you think he got to
that level
or do we get levels below hello we got
talents we have capos
we're getting crystalia we're getting
crystalline theovonne
everybody that was on that video where
he was crying yes like that group of
people okay came together and like your
career is going to be over if you don't
why are hey can i ask you la [ __ ]
why you're all defending brendan shaw
because this guy is not good enough to
defend and i know a lot of people go oh
the it's just a meme now to make fun of
brendan shop because he's not funny no
no no we were saying he wasn't funny a
long time ago when it wasn't a meme he's
not funny
they called me
a coward
a [ __ ] you've always been a positive
i'm sorry that's the thing
and and um
they said they would expose me they said
that all these things and i was in
oklahoma shooting a show
and i was at dinner and i was by myself
and i was getting it was very traumatic
for me and
it was based on
whatever they did on the live now
imagine now what's going to happen with
now this it's good you said that i think
it's good that you're saying that
because them you should you should stand
up for yourself yeah
first off
shut up
ethan that you should stand up for
yourself [ __ ] you
i'm not defending what bobby lee is
doing but i'm trying to look at it from
that his position is like
they can ruin my career yeah like
they're gonna get paid i need money out
here exactly matt tv ain't around no
more this [ __ ] isn't gonna [ __ ] me if
i'm poor exactly probably [ __ ] brendan
chubb
these guys probably did [ __ ] brendon i
don't know if that's true or not but i
wouldn't be surprised
every time ever all the time but to beat
but they did it they took it there
they're very unacceptable
when that happened he called me like
shell shocked and crying at which point
i said give me his number
i'm a man
i have a feeling that he cries i think
crying is something that bobby lee
doesn't really cries a lot yeah he's a
crier
poor bobby hey bobby
you're the best man the man that has
feelings like what the [ __ ]
oh good any by the way frozen write this
down anything that hilda likes do the
opposite of it
what's her name she looks like a hilda
doesn't she like a gila [ __ ] is
she like a hilda
like a witch a witch named hillary
monster gila monster all right well it's
not like she killed a bunch of [ __ ]
middle eastern people or anything
are we talking about when he's like
being spoken she wants somebody say that
again for the further
over everybody with my terrible acne
oh god she sounds like
like an israeli who's also actually
[ __ ] yeah yeah you're right like an
israeli with down syndrome
say that again for the people be on the
specials
we love men that can cry
okay i have a feeling that bobby's chick
does not love men that could cry you're
speaking for a lot of people here i need
to be with a man who cries and has
emotions because when i was very young
girl i was turned into a terminator that
just murdered palestinian children so i
have no feelings left
you went i look at my baby and feel
nothing you went from israeli
to marsh and then and then to borat yeah
my wife i'm nice
and children very nice
bottom
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the height of the chaos
was when that happened at which point i
said i'm so sorry dude yeah that's so
[ __ ] up well to both of you also not
having like the balls to talk to you he
has the balls to go and fight people but
like why does he gotta go do you even
know what's going on
uh let me answer that question for you
um murderer
uh allegedly i don't know that's true or
not she have to be on the screen dude
yes um i want everyone to know how bad
it could get
for you in life
let me explain something to you
possible
possibly allegedly i don't know if you
ever did
uh you have never been convicted but um
this is
it's it's it's
women like this
that we're gonna breed more bobby lee's
in the world the more ethan's in the
world than men are going to lose all
testosterone and then it's just this is
why the world's going to [ __ ] because
we're pandering to women women that look
like this that look like this
and by the way the other thing the
reason brian like that exotic beauty and
let me answer your question
the re the reason that you feel like you
want to play some elden ring right now
oh my god she does look like an evil
[ __ ] monster
so look
the reason that brendan's doing that by
the way why didn't you talk to you why
he's using other intermediaries why he's
doing that is because in his head
brendan thinks that he could operate on
the same level as rogan does
you know what i mean like oh i'll just
have people do something he's like the
underboss that's starting to get a
little too out of line when the boss is
in it now exactly and then jack
nicholson's joker ends up shooting him
[Laughter]
like the balls to talk to you he has the
balls to go and fight people but like
why does he because most men would
prefer to get hit in the head than have
to talk to a woman do you understand
that do you get especially women like
you yeah
you gotta go do you even know what's
going on when you go
what are you guys talking about you
didn't know what it was happening i
don't know number one i don't you were
okay first of all
this is going good for him yeah they
were like we have evidence of something
right
so they said right they go we have 50
pages no they said 300 pages whatever of
of evidence brandon can't even read bro
how the [ __ ] that guy bringing 300 pages
of anything that guy's barely illiterate
are you kidding me this is where i
300 pages and i believe they do have
probably some dirt on him too
well i mean i'm starting to wonder like
remember when everyone was leaking all
like oh bobby lee got his dicks up by
his cousin when he was a kid remember
that i believe that that stuff coming
that that stuff being amplified was kind
of a warning shot to him i really do
well remember too the 12 year old
prostitute oh yeah that's right mexico
or whatever i'm starting to wonder if
that's maybe what they're referring to i
think that there's some
there's a disconnect between
food there's a disconnect between the
information he's being fed by his team i
don't think it's all him like he's just
like bent pixels is the word you're
looking for
i have 300 pages of of proof that um of
an ip address that let's link bobby's
ethan thank you bobby computer i was
like do you realize
that's not how it works is is brandon's
people saying they've back traced an ip
called tech stupid boss
phone calls on his ipad
saying that and basically that we've had
we've launched an attack on him for the
past five six years and i told brendan i
was like oh my god he's doing the jrc3
yeah that
everybody hates him wait does brendan
think that everybody hates him because
of bobby lee
not because of him and his personality
and the way he acts it's been an
astroturf internet uh bot campaign led
by bobby lee and that's very racist of
you brendan shaw to just assume that the
guy who looks korean and chinese is just
a computer genius yeah seriously some of
them are just stupid like frozen
brandon with all due respect like you're
not an afterthought for us like did you
see when you played the wrong video
earlier all right fair enough you stupid
frozen
uh oh hot dog
why would we as a company to dedicate
five six years to this harassment on
reddit when my sweet love oh because a
lot
her sweet lover her what sweet lover oh
a lot of people hate brandon there's
like a whole like movie so yeah he's
trying to people yeah the people the
whole movement is called people with
eyes and ears comedy fans yes yes yes
the only people that don't are the ones
elizabeth warren are getting hearing
aids for her
is that on you guys
yes and so now we're at a point where
it's like well he says he has proof that
me
over the last five or six years that
i've been on reddit you mean okay
everybody
i've been spending my time
first of all number one i don't own a
computer i don't even know how to buy
one really you know man amazon oh wait
you need a computer for that he really
does
number two right i don't know
you mentioned calling amazon to get a
computer hello amazon this is bobby lee
of mad tv
i need a computer hello hello hello
hello hanging up on me get on reddit
i've asked her how do you get on it what
is it right right i'm just not
tech savvy in that way you know it's
shameful to say but uh
shameful you're what are you like 50 60
50. yeah
so you are the best looking 50 year old
by the way thank you thank you you are
so youthful and your skin is still
stopping
so he was going you're doing this we can
trace the url back to your house and
you're the leader of this reddit group
i'm like bro first of all if you look at
from what i so there's one thing bobby
lee is known for it's his strategy and
his leadership skills so wait wait wait
wait
to imply that that's what's happening
brendan's people
because this is this is how dumb brand
it is brennan's people would have to
have convinced him that not only were
they able to get back and access to
reddit because that's only we get the ip
you would have to get back-end access to
reddit because they tell you you can't
click somebody's name on reddit and see
their ip so they get back-end access to
reddit then they had to get a warrant to
get the address of who it belonged to
because you just can't you could you you
could put an ip on the internet and see
what state they're in or
even idea but it's not going to go oh
this ip is merch no
here if you look at reddit there are
pages about me as well
i don't know
can i tell you something
i'm gonna drop a bombshell on you guys
no no no no that's his wife
i've been in technology my whole life
yeah
people that don't know [ __ ] anything
you're not in technology you made the
vape niche video years ago on youtube
you're not in the tech business you're
not elon musk flying private jets across
the world to solve
[ __ ] starlink problems
you have a podcast sir hey merch i'm in
technology the unmitigated call of this
man
technology say that [ __ ] yeah but i
think it's impossible to get that right
he doesn't have it when anybody says
they have it i think proof against you
but ethan i think that
thank you i'm really glad that she
chimed in don't ever believe them we can
get them assault to discredit them even
if you've raped or murdered them
i again i'll defend him in this scenario
by saying i think his team is giving him
a lot of wrong information well whatever
ultimately for example like yeah brendan
you're really funny yeah brandon don't
worry about training legs if you barely
use those in the ufc anyway
[Laughter]
you don't need core strength in the ufc
oh [ __ ] you're just gonna knock them out
slugger uh let me see here hold on
you got this like pumping homer up yeah
pumping over up now you know what don't
even don't even compare the two because
homer actually could at least take blows
this at least homer could take a punch
this this is this reminds me of this
this this oh you're just gonna pretend
i'm not here huh just like robin
williams agent pretends he's still funny
hello hey phil it's robin williams
that's hilarious i just wanted to make
sure the meeting is still on for 2 30
tomorrow otherwise i got to go to that
chinese dentist get it 2 30.
you son of a [ __ ] i had a mouth full of
coffee god you are funny and that is
real
that's brendan's people that's really
very because think about it he's a cash
cow right he is a cash cow so
um
you lie to him and go you're great and
look the person to blame for this a big
part of this is rogan right like rogan
if you're logan created this monster
yeah he did
him and i uh like um were able to find
common ground it's like look i think i'm
receiving wrong information and i'm like
i can i can understand that i can
forgive you he's just trying to scare
you dan is it oh dan is our tech wizard
he's walking away is he gassy did you
just have like a bunch of pizza and beer
before no he's always twitchy and gassy
and he's just a big he's a frumpy
monster yeah with a bag of chips dan for
crazy
what's up
is it possible to get uh ip logs from
reddit that proves that bobby is posting
[ __ ] about brandon not without like
working at reddit i mean exactly
he's right that's exactly what i was
saying though you can't just get that
federal subpoena
um
yeah i don't need i didn't know what he
was saying i actually think we should i
could call him right now and get
clarification no no do not call him
bobby is stressed out oh god
i don't know if he looks tired or just
super asian yeah it's very he's always
looked like this so wait where frozen
can you grow your hair out like bobby
lee please thank you i want you to look
at one of the surf ninjas guys
thank you
wow and if not that like the roofio
mohawk yeah it's gonna take a while so
start yeah start now roofie and mohawk
could probably accomplish there you go
let's go with ruffian mullet oh i like
the can you get an asian mullet can you
do a mullet that'd be dope
thank you or maybe be like jimmy wang
yang yes yes
hey him and i are okay now i don't i
doubt i'm gonna say this no after this
no you will not be able to i agree with
that i promise you this and this is this
has opened no you know what i can i say
quite the opposite i think now that this
is so big
right back up brandon can't make that
make a move anymore without people going
like
yeah and especially with somebody like
bobby lee who is a little beta like he's
a little i don't dislike bobby i know
some people do i don't i think he was
funny on mad tv i think bobby lee has
made me laugh more than brendan has
bobby lee is [ __ ] hilarious yeah so i
don't hate him and i think you're
picking on
he's brennan is picking on the weakest
member of that crew oh yeah because he's
there's anybody that can they can push
around other than bobby lee right
because he can't do this to [ __ ]
calling or dalia or or any of these
people like go [ __ ] you go literally go
[ __ ] yourself
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] but bobby lee
they pick on him on purpose
every crew has to have one every time
somebody picks on an asian person like
this it makes me mad anybody that does
it
anybody that does it is terrible
it's it's horrible it's just you should
all be picking on brendan's job right
don't pick on helpless asian people yeah
little asian you know stop end asian
hate and asian hate you know what i mean
all right but what about shut up frozen
i'm gonna give frozen compliment that
was good he's one of the best straight
men in the [ __ ] industry i don't care
what anybody says [ __ ] dean martin
he's [ __ ] amazing all right
no no i'm not fine i'm fine i'm probably
fine totally fine i'm just saying
you're not fine bobby you're a lot of
things but fine it's not one no you're
probably i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine i'm
fine i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine who has
more
neurological
and mental problems ethan klein or bobby
lee because like ethan klein's manifest
themselves and way more physically with
the twitching and the burping and the
just being but like bobby's
a [ __ ] wreck but bobby bobby i think
with mental [ __ ] i think bobby's worse
for sure
this has opened up a whirlpool even body
language like you know even bobby's body
language is somebody who is
in a defensive stance bobby lee has
never known a day on this earth where
he's not been abused yeah you know what
i mean he's like he's like a sex traffic
victim that was never let out of the
container shift yes
one in the back it was hiding in the
corner yes yeah he has a he's sitting
he's sleeping next to a bucket of his
own piss and [ __ ]
i'm not a [ __ ] right i'm
x to doubt on that one i'm just saying
the thing is is that you guys
don't do stand up right no right so oh
my god i'm always around them that's
what i was saying earlier but he is
always around i always have so i'm
trying to play it politically right i
that is the most honest i've ever heard
a comic be can i can at least give bobby
credit for that
that that is that i don't want to get in
trouble and have to be around the
bullies
and that's at least he's being honest i
don't actually like brendan yeah playing
politics he literally just he's saying
the truth at least that's the truth
though i'm trying to play it politically
right i feel like i was assaulted for
something that i didn't do at all i
don't know even know what the [ __ ]
they're talking you truly have nothing
to do with it i have nothing to do with
and yet i was being you know i mean um
they put it all on hill right because
they're using you to try to control what
kalila is doing right right so um you
know i you know i went to therapy and
what's her name
kalanip what is it
kalila kalila i think if she was if she
were kalanapin bobby would be a lot
caller yeah seriously
about it you know i mean talk about it
yes yes you name her [ __ ] podcast so
goddamn boring today because it's like
it was just so traumatic and these were
my friends and i had no idea what the
[ __ ] they were talking were
did you see little things coming were my
friends talking about right and so
my whole thing was let's never talk
about it again
ever right and and now here we are on h3
you getting [ __ ] dragged through with
your girlfriend again making her go for
round two
do you think she gets off on it sexually
it feels like it she likes to dominate
people yeah brushed on the rug so that i
can go to comedy clubs and look them in
the eye and be
cordial right but now right this is a
whole nother
[ __ ] thing
that i gotta deal with now yeah i see i
see your point yeah it just sucks
because
they are yeah it sounds like you they're
trying to bully you and it sucks that
you're in this position now yeah where
you have to it's like a boy it sounds
like some [ __ ] but she's also
bullying sports like she like yeah at
least at least you don't have to go home
with brendan every night like you have
to go you have to go home with her you
know what i mean
let's be honest dude a lot of these
[ __ ] guys
have accusations against them
and it's a [ __ ] boys club and they're
all protecting each other and i'm not
saying that one did one
one did one what's up with the
toothpicks i i know that's
what is that a thing it's in honor of
razor ramon oh okay fair enough we're
talking about okay five
i'm not saying anyone did anything
specifically but it's like hey
your girl's out of line you know you got
to protect ethan somebody's probably
been alpha male 1 in his life too huh
yeah and looks like why are you doing a
new york guido accent
it'd be like hey man you're like being
like really toxic right and maybe i
can't have you around anymore
pick the boys and it's [ __ ] up
somebody pointed out that that that he
was doing um keenan playing ortiz
that that that uh kenan
ortiz
is is that is that the one
uh when keenan was playing
uh david ortiz hold on this this is what
he was doing is what they're saying
poppy uh what's your favorite opening
day tradition lunch
i'm sorry all all of that is lunch yeah
that's right
pasta
told you i told you what he's doing
refresh
i'm not going to put i'm not going to
put it on the screen obviously because
it's snl but this is what they're
pointing out he ripped it off because to
be fair keenan is doing a really good
david ortiz impression that's very good
he really is yeah keenan is very funny
all the players this is what he's doing
in the clubhouse and we all have a big
lunch
we're gonna have my photo
lechon rosado
pasta little gonna be
[Laughter]
gap in the tooth and everything that
that is what shaw was doing that is what
shaw was doing
it's bowling [ __ ] dude
yeah and to and on flagrant to andrew
schultz's podcast he was like i
contacted kalila and i'm like no i asked
bobby for your new number and i really
wanted both he wanted to talk to you so
oh okay
all right so let's that's a two-way
street right let's be real all right he
wants i don't like the narrative that he
was he came to me with with this because
it took
months or like two months before he even
wanted to come directly to the source
and i would i want to talk to women i
mean again i'm going to defend i need to
finish i'm different i get it yeah i'm
the same way you contact the dude and be
like yo can you tell you [ __ ] shut up
please
she's got some [ __ ] to say say my
[ __ ] face please
knock this [ __ ] off
he saw the first podcast on trash
tuesday and said hey i really didn't
like what you said it would have alluded
to me that's not good for me and then i
would have said i understand that i
didn't realize that you would be getting
extra harassment from all of this i
apologize i will not say it again it's
also not a cancelable offense to hit on
a woman it's not a big deal it was an
anecdote yeah and it could have been
resolved right then and there and i did
tell him that when i spoke to him a week
ago i said this was a very very simple
thing so from here on out moving forward
so it was him hitting on you even though
you said it wasn't him hitting on you
now you're saying it wasn't hitting on
you i'm just trying to keep up word
let's shake on it if you have a problem
with something i say come to me directly
and he said the same thing so we're good
we're good i promise you okay promise
you we're not no i promise you're not
and i promise you there's a wave coming
now and and that's it
unfortunately i i agree with bobby just
because i don't think they're even
though you love this by the way
but i also love that
ethan's what he's doing is he he made
him say it but now he's being a
disingenuous jew while making money off
of this right kind of like a shape
shifter yeah
he's changing shapes gonna be happy
that it's out there that they're [ __ ]
bowling bobby
because those are these are elements
that i was never gonna share these are
elements that i was gonna just keep
but is that okay like it's enough it's
okay to do you do whatever you want
not okay
but you gotta live your life yeah you
gotta live your life it's okay
right
i'm doing first of all number one um
would i say that they're
friends of mine anymore no they're out
right i stopped following them on social
media so we could figure out who they
are by the way to see who we stopped by
seeing you stop following this should be
simple it probably out already it's
already on reddit yeah okay right and i
did what i'm doing to protect myself
you know what they did was not off what
a friend would do but he did apologize
to you bobby brendan did
yeah
yeah he did apologize but what i'm
saying is is that
the the world didn't know what had
happened
right right and so it's like you know
those are the elements that i was going
to just kind of go you know let's brush
that to the side right
um i had my own way of processing it and
dealing with it just politically yeah
because i'm i do stand up every night
and i start i'm just around now
you know i have you might not be doing
stand-up every night
seriously you better hope that podcast
takes off bud now pick and choose where
i go up
right i do yeah i know yeah i mean i
have to go and i go there that night
because now they're there right and it's
just me this has made it very difficult
for me
you know and um
it sucks i'm sorry yeah i mean you know
it's out there and that's why i wish you
didn't do a live podcast
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
yeah yeah
um i like to believe that this is
i better get a lot of teddy fresh [ __ ] i
mean bro i got i got i've got the ex i
don't i got the bulldozer
forever
forever you got it
but i don't like the idea of um because
of this now your life's going to be
worse
i don't know i've we've always lived
which goes to show you something they
always thought bobby lee was a nerd
because the new kid on the block was
brendan schaub he showed up bobby lee's
been in that friends group way longer
than shaw bobby's been that friendly
since mad tv if you really think about
it right the calendar broke allen worked
with the guy on man tv like so we're
talking about these are dudes that have
known each other
so
i mean it goes to show you brendan's a
new thing because brennan's the new wob
tom's on rogan all the time so we got to
be nice to brandon give a shout out to
my boy who always stays out of all this
will sasso yeah good for him lived under
like
not letting anyone bully us
and
i don't think you should tolerate that
behavior and if it means that you're
gonna
have to not perform
on the same night as them
maybe it's gonna be better for you
though because you don't have to carry
this pretend and pretend that you're
like part of this group this men's group
that everything is good there
this men's group i hate her
nobody's bullying everybody yeah i'm
sure eliza schlesinger isn't also part
by the way it's not just a dude group
there's plenty of female comics that
from what i've heard and i won't say any
names get passed around that little
group
a lot like it's [ __ ] hot potato but
you're [ __ ] the potato
weddings that i'm going to
right how many times you go to weddings
you hate other people there you go [ __ ]
that guy i don't go to jewish weddings
jokes on you ethan
jokes
on
you bud
i think we got i think that's pretty
much the heart of it
i don't go to jewish wedding go to a
[ __ ] family event you hate half the
people there no i'm not jewish i'm not
jewish sorry my family my family loves
you even when we hate each other it
sounds like we know if you're in front
of it sounds like we don't but we love
each other honestly that's the real
thing
oh [ __ ] look at me good good luck to
bobby lee i i actually do like bobby lee
so you know uh good luck to bobby lee on
what his comedy career i think he'll be
okay
no i don't mean the comedy stuff i mean
it does it does kind of suck you know
jump joking uh good luck kid with your
comedy career i'm only joking can i get
50 year old